[Music]
i
love these movies they're all so
different they're so singular and every
one of them expands our ideas of what a
documentary can be but with documentary
it's like you're on your own each person
has to stumble their way into it in
their own way i'm sure the most silence
that we took in
uh and the most deep concentrated
thoughts that we took in happened in
2020 which really allows you to
think about what type of stories you
want to tell like almost like going
bowling and you put up the kitty rails
like fear and anxiety and worry and
concern
was what we had to lean into it a lot
yes my film is an animated film but in
its call it's a documentary and there
was no other way i could tell the story
than doing it animated and yes it's
expensive but it's worth it and as a
filmmaker it's such a luxury to be able
to play with time in a way you can
expand it you can contract and really
condense time and you can put one single
day or one hour one minute and one
second into a microscope and really
exaggerate and expand that moment and
linger in that moment
like once i work with a participant in a
film they're we're like family and and
sometimes that means like bailing them
out of jail or like having dinner with
like i'm just like i have their family
members you know going forward